setting her sights on Sachi corporal
Amanda Lightfoot one of two British
soldiers taking time out from the Army
to focus on an Olympic target Amanda and
Lance Bombardier lead Jackson of both
serving soldiers compete under the
British flag in the biathlon in Russia
their sport is a demanding combination
of cross-country skiing and rifle
shooting and the Army has a long
tradition of sending athletes to the
Olympics Amanda is the latest product
completing a journey that began in the
sand of Iraq I was out there and there
was a officer looking for fit females to
join the regimental ski team for the agc
Corps and I got picked up from there
basically originally I thought I was
gonna be going downhill skiing I'd never
actually been on snow in my life let
alone stand on cross-country skis so
that was a crazy journey to come from
there and I remember my first days on
snow I could hardly even stand up you
know and then you're getting tall the
ski up a hill with a rifle attached to
your back the British team made their
final preparations in Ridd now in the
Italian Tyrol the scenery is idyllic the
competition is fierce this is the key to
the biathlon the shooting the skiers
arrive here with their heart's pounding
upwards of 175 beats a minute they've
got to shoot five targets 50 metres away
no more than two inches across be in and
out less than 30 seconds
you have to be up early to get your mat
down on the range before the Germans
they're one of many teams with far
larger resources than the British thanks
to the sports huge popularity in Europe
biathlon World Cup events draw crowds of
up to 40,000 with millions more watching
on TV the British athletes and their
two-man support team could only compete
because the army allows them to train
full-time the Ministry of Defence is to
cut direct funding to the sport after
Saatchi and while a new sponsor will
help fill the gap the sport faces a
challenging future I think there's a lot
of respect from the other nations but
norther actually we are lacking in
resources lacking in participation
numbers and also the fact that we don't
start doing biathlon until 1012 years
after you know the rest of the world
kind of start doing battles but with a
wealth of military experience they've
served in Afghanistan Iraq Bosnia and
Northern Ireland between them they're
now chasing medals of a different kind
Paul Kelso Sky News